he reescrito el teorema de stocks por
aquí y en lo que quiero enfocarme ahora
este es el teorema stoxx el que está
escrito acá abajo lo que quiero
enfocarme en este vídeo es la cuestión
de la orientación porque ya hemos visto
que hay dos orientaciones para nuestra
curva y curva frontera por ejemplo
porque podríamos ir en esta dirección
que es contraria a las manecillas del
reloj o bien podríamos ir en esta
dirección que a diferencia del caso
anterior va justo en dirección de las
manecillas del reloj entonces tenemos
dos formas de pensar el recorrido de
esta curva y también tenemos dos formas
de pensar cuando elegimos un vector
normal a la superficie es decir si en
este punto podríamos tomar un vector
normal que apunte digamos de esta forma
o bien podríamos considerar el vector
que apunta hacia adentro de la
superficie entonces tenemos aquí estos
ejemplos de las formas en que podremos
orientar estos dos detalles por el queso
en la curva frontera y el vector normal
entonces este déjenme quitar esto
tenemos que garantizar que sean
consistentes para poder utilizar el
teorema de stocks entonces hay dos
formas de pensarlo como ya les dije
entonces si por ejemplo nos tomamos el
primer caso en donde nuestro vector
normal está apuntando hacia afuera aquí
tenemos nuestro vector normal n entonces
la forma en que yo lo más fácil digamos
lo comprendo es poner una personita aquí
digamos que este soy yo ok
y mi cabeza está apuntando hacia el asia
hacia la dirección en donde apunta el
vector normal entonces este que soy yo
voy a estar corriendo a lo largo de esta
curva pero siempre cuidando que mi lado
izquierdo se quede y digamos que la
superficie completa esté de mi lado
izquierdo ok entonces yo estaría
corriendo
de esta forma
saleh y así es como yo puedo ir este
digamos recorriendo esta trayectoria
ahora qué pasa si el vector normal no es
este si no fuera el que está en sentido
contrario entonces
más o menos la misma curva ok
y aquí bueno pues tenemos nuestra
superficie
y entonces qué tal que ahora no estoy
considerando ese si no estoy
considerando el vector normal que apunta
hacia adentro ok entonces ahí nuevamente
yo voy a tener que considerar me a mí
mismo que estoy ahí corriendo pero ahora
mi cabeza tiene que apuntar hacia la
dirección del vector normal
entonces ahí me voy a poner yo a correr
y otra vez ahora tengo que considerar
que la superficie debe quedar del lado
izquierdo de qué forma
digo esto es un poquito más difícil de
visualizar pero de qué forma queda del
lado izquierdo pues esto pasa si yo lo
recorro en este sentido ok es decir la
superficie por ejemplo aquí si yo lo voy
recorriendo de esa forma si estoy todo
de cabeza pues en realidad estaría
viendo de mi lado izquierdo digamos como
una alberca verdad aquí está este es
como como el agujero y ahí tiene la
profundidad no en el caso anterior si yo
voy corriendo de esta forma de mi lado
izquierdo lo que estoy viendo es
esencialmente como una colina ok
entonces digamos que estoy corriendo
alrededor de una colina entonces
dependiendo del vector normal esto nos
dicta cómo recorrer la trayectoria
frontera otra forma de pensarlo es como
nos comentó una persona en youtube y es
imaginar que la superficie es en
realidad la tapa de una botella entonces
déjenme
y dibujando la botella
ahí está mi botella
un poco dispareja
un poco de trabajo estoy haciendo mi
mejor esfuerzo crean duelo
entonces vamos a pin
nuestra botella
cuándo
darle su fondo y un poco de profundidad
sale entonces por ejemplo aquí vamos a
ponerle digamos el reflejo
es una botella de adeveras y lo que
vamos a decir como les comentaba es que
la superficie la superficie es la tapa
de una de esta botella entonces qué es
lo que pasa si yo esta botella ya muchos
conocen o han experimentado esa
sensación de abrir una botella hacia
donde yo la giro
es digamos de esta forma para abrirla
quiere decir que la tapa de la botella
sube entonces el vector normal apunta
hacia arriba si lo vemos de esta forma
como giro yo la tapa es esencialmente
hacia donde se ve bueno como recorro la
la trayectoria que es la frontera y eso
me determina hacia dónde se mueve la
tapa que es hacia dónde apunta el vector
normal si yo al revés la la la tapa
digamos la sierra entonces la tapa en
realidad está bajando y quién quién
estaría siendo el vector normal es el
contrario porque se está cerrando la
botella entonces ahí tienen dos formas
para pensarlo pero lo importante que hay
que tener en mente es que las formas de
la superficie pueden ponerse muy
complicadas y muy locas así que hay que
tener cuidado a la hora de orientar